bonsoir philippin murray remercie d'être
avec nous l'an gris et la pologne qui
empêche l'europe de tourner en rond
c'est plus que des réserves c'est un
veto oui c'est un veto tout à fait du
plan de relance de l'union européenne
donc qui est pour l'instant bloquée on
se rappelle qu'il a été proposé en mai
négocié en juin juillet et en fait on se
retrouve six mois après avec pas de plan
de relance alors que l'union européenne
a dit c'est nous qui relance on est donc
les états ne relance pas vraiment donc
c'est un vrai problème
le budget européen aussi bloqué pour les
sept années à venir pour l'instant et
donc on a bien compris le sujet c'est
que la pologne et de la hongrie ne
veulent pas être mise au pas par l'union
européenne en fait qui propose de
pouvoir couper les aides d'état si
jamais la pologne et la hongrie
n'applique pas toutes les bonnes
politiques comme on veut parce que ça
veut dire quoi l'état de droit en fait
c'est l'état de droit européen
est ce que veulent les polonais les
hongrois c'est respecter leurs étapes
droit aveux et respecter la souveraineté
populaire qui a réélu le gouvernement
polonais qui a reconduit déjà deux fois
monsieur rohrbach
effectivement il ya deux sujets
immigration pour la pologne et la
hongrie où l'union européenne veut
imposer son agenda devra poser des
migrations et les pays ne le veulent pas
et les médias et l'état et les médias et
la justice où l'organisation ne convient
pas à l'union européenne
on voit que l'union européenne il ya un
problème démocratique parce qu'elle est
en train de violer la souveraineté
populaire de ces deux pays selon -
concernant l'immigration c'est une chose
concernant le plan de relance après
cette crise est ce que finalement la
hongrie et la pologne ne devrait pas
jouer le jeu de la solidarité comme le
font les autres pays
si mais le problème c'est qu'on veut
leur imposer de l'immigration et qu'ils
ne veulent pas et donc la seule arme qui
l'on peut ne pas être mis au pas de
façon plus ou moins définitive puisque
dans ce cas là lui aubaine pour à leur
couper les subsides qu'ils ont la seule
façon qu'ils ont trouvée c'est cela
c'est que l'union européenne revienne en
arrière sur lier l'état de droit
européen entre guillemets avec avec les
plans d' aide à ces deux pays quoi mais
en fait on voit que l'union européenne
est un petit peu échoué bloquer le plan
avec le breakbeat n'avance pas ça fait
le divorce et il faudrait que ça avance
vite parce que les pêcheurs france est
inquiétant pour eux et pour nos
exportations vers l'angleterre le budget
bloquer le plan de relance est bloqué ce
qui pose des vrais problèmes d'ailleurs
puisque la france l'italie l'espagne
pour avoir des ddd récession de plus de
10% qu'il avait les états unis ont que
deux pour cent si on fait des aides très
rapidement et puis ce dossier de
l'immigration qui est bloquée de flux
d'immigration qui est bloqué depuis six
ans où personne n'est d'accord sur le
sujet le problème de l'union européenne
c'est qu'elle veut que tout le monde est
exactement le même modèle
alors que les pays ont des intérêts et
des visions différentes aujourd'hui est
ce qu'il ya un risque d'arriver un point
de non-retour vous les avez évoqué ces
sujets de division il est compliqué de
se mettre d'accord à 27
comment justement vous voyez l'avenir de
l'union européenne dans ces conditions
on voit plutôt une union européenne qui
est sclérosé comme un bloqués comme un
bateau un peu échoué sur la plage qui
arrivent pas avancer et ça vient alors
je pense qu'il y aura un accord quand
même c'est à dire que l'union européenne
va sans doute essayer de retirer ce que
donc ce lien entre ce qu'elle appelle
l'état droit aux biens ou de l'amoindrir
fortement et les aide à la hongrie à la
pologne à tous les pays
je pense que la hongrie la pologne nous
représente bien parce que sinon la
france serait mise au pas aussi par
l'union européenne qui pourrait à lui
capté de l'argent par notre budget de
cons
répulsion l'union européenne et ne pas
nous en rendre par les aides si on fait
plaise pas le problème c'est que la
méthode de l'union européenne le traité
de l'union européenne qui a été votée
par les parlementaires français en 2008
avec sarkozy qui avait été refusé par
référendum c'est une union toujours plus
étroite avec toujours plus de pouvoirs
pour l'union européenne et donc ça
devient au bout d'un moment inacceptable
c'est là où c'est en train de
complètement bloquée je pense et qu'elle
porte de sortie trouver aujourd'hui une
porte de sortie honorable pour l'union
dans quel sens soit elles seraient
formés si elle le doit
si elle le doit bien ça je pense que ça
serait de rendre de ne pas faire ces
lois au métro palais pays comme elle le
fait et de ne pas faire grosso modo
arrêter d'être dans une union de plus en
plus étroites comme l est le problème
c'est que c'est le traité de l'union
européenne qui est comme ça et qui
bloque tout et puis c'est les logiques
des fonctionnement des institutions
européennes qui est de prendre toujours
plus de pouvoir de récupérer toujours
plus de pouvoir sur les ai pas il
faudrait au contraire que l'union
européenne rende des pouvoirs aux états
pour que les états puissent s'organiser
eux-mêmes selon leur propre intérêt et
je pense que tout le monde y gagnerait
merci beaucoup philippin muraire
économise d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france